ドライヤーの
先端です今日は外れ社長です皆さん避ける組ってご存知でしょうか最低食べる組なん
ですけども羽の中長いサイズ熱が出たみたいですこちら長い避ける組すごいとこれで
ほぼ原寸大これぐらいの長さの組でございます全然4前 j たん茶煎茶も話みたいに
メーターが降っております避ける組の長いバージョンってことはすごい避けるって事
大永江
じゃないピック者と別とムチみたいで力があるんですけど咲いてみましょうか
をはこんな形になりますうーん
甘いここでよく思ったんですけども40センチを普通に売り出してなると1人でこれ
から食べるのが当たり前だなって思ってたるこのサイズにしたんですよね
つまり40センチが普通の人の食べる確保すると
10m ぐらい食えるんじゃないかなって思ったわけですよ
1回計算させてくれこれで40cm から3つ食べると
1.2m ピッ点22点43てロック4.8へ6.07.2発展の96
100というわけで10m 避ける文だったらマー坊さんはほど北にもって食べ
トニーカナーンと思ったわけでございますよ前著
よ
あった
見栄えが悪いな
b
[音楽]
ええええええ
2も避ける組っていうのは来なさいて食べるんですよねこういうくださいっても
ちょびっとずつこれでパッと食べるのがサクラウグイなんでそれ僕も割かずに10
メートルという
これまでは避ける組では想像できるようなじゃない距離をこれが走り抜けるわけでしょ
なんたる贅沢ピアンを何が何でも食べます
ていただきます
どうぞ
うんな損害はダメでしょうんおいしい
[音楽]
すごい
甘えちょっと想像の5倍から枚数大
うーん
[音楽]
食べます
やつを持ってはきついな味がずっとあのぶどうグミなんで口がおかしくなってきます街
が受け付けないっていうかまおいしいんですけど同じ奴ばっかりでちょっとも
無理だな
っていうのが本当のところです
食べますけどね
[音楽]
ん
goo
この応募ベルはぁっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
う
強でもうぶりで多分これぞ食べると末行く
[音楽]
僕の体を避けるんでああ
ただいま範囲というわけでちょっと時間を置いて帰ってきました
お腹がちょっとだいぶ消化されて楽になったんですけどもポイントがありまして味に
飽きちゃうぶどうグミばっかり食って一緒の境地になったことありますかもうすごいよ
体の中もか10円ですからね味が来ないようにえびフィレオとお茶を準備したのでこれ
でちょっと味を交わさせながら組送っていこうと思います残り4メートルちょい頑張っ
ていきます
ぎゃんっ
うまいかむいて食べるとおいしいうん全然怒らん
はいあと2.4m ですちょっとまでビデオ食らわないとメディアの本当にねあのー方
もきついですけど味の日がすごい
やばいファンする存在ですよね
ずっ
[音楽]
ぽい
謎ゆず説明いただきます
[音楽]
ua
花序を張ってだっけね男女
wh
[音楽]